now it's thursday and that means it's
puppy pig skin
picks sponsored by subaru of las vegas
john's with us from the animal
foundation
nice to see you happy holidays you too
sheriff yes and who's this lovely little
girl this is rosie
she's five years old she's a cutie she's
46 pounds
um she's a little chunky for her her
size just a little overweight
okay she's kind of a mix of maybe
several things
oh yeah she's a heinz 57 but she's a
real sweet dog
she is sweet how did you find rosie um
actually the story of rosie is her
owner passed away oh so that's why we
have her so okay
she'd be lovely to go into a great new
home is she good with dogs other animals
uh dogs yes cats a little iffy oh okay
and you're uh still asking for fosters
we are we still have foster for the
holidays so if somebody has
room in their home and their heart they
can you know volunteer
go on the website and it's under the
volunteer tab and they can
foster a dog through the holidays and
help out a lot get out of the shelter
get them out of the shelter right
let them have a christmas tree exactly
okay all right rosie we're gonna let you
pick
it's the raiders and the jets this
weekend you go for it
you'll be our picker let's pick a team
rosie picked the jets
okay i'm sorry i was laughing the jets
have not won a single game this year so
raiders
you've got to do it this weekend well if
you'd like to adopt rosie
or if you'd like to be a foster human
for
some really deserving doggies there call
the number on your screen
702-384-3333
nate that is just
awesome i love the animal foundation and
uh what a
lovely young lady all right clark